. Herzlich willkommen zum Zodcast-Ufo mit mir, Erster und Dir, Florentin Will. Vielen Dank dafür und das war ein ganz fantastisches Intro von Felix. Ja, vielen Dank. Felix ist ein toller Name. Gibt es eigentlich den Zodcast von Zodmonte, dieser Firma? eigentlich perfekt. Ein Filmpodcast seit Zodcast? Können wir das pitchen? Nee, das ist die größte erste Einnahme der Florentin Will, nee der Will und Tizze GbR, kurz unseren Namen vergessen. Übrigens vielen Dank an den Fan, der uns die Tasse geschickt hat, unsere erste eigene Bürotasse. Wir hätten uns doch Jack nennen sollen. Ja. Wir hatten entweder Tizze und William GbR oder Jack Productions, wie das Tier mit den drei coolen Buchstaben. Oder Felix, auch einen schönen. Stimmt eigentlich, ja, aber so einen Namen. Felix. Ihr seid die Jungs von Felix, ne? Ja. Ja, der Zottcast, vielleicht bald auch in eure Kühlteam. Das wäre super geil, wenn man den raushauen könnte.
Gibt es nicht irgendwann einfach einen Podcast für alles?
Einfach wirklich alles hat einen Podcast, jedes einzelne Produkt hat einen Podcast.
Eigentlich nicht.
Ja, haut mal raus einfach, haut mal raus.
Ich will so einen Podcast, wo Leute Joghurts testen und wo man dann einfach die ersten 20 Minuten nur so ein...
Cremig, ja, cremig, aber hat auch was Wässriges. Und der ist abgelaufen. Oh, oh, der ist seit drei Jahren abgelaufen. Der ist ja 60 Jahren abgelaufen. Wie kommt der denn hier rein? Robert? Robert? Können wir in Notarzt Robert? Er hat alten Joghurt ge... Oh, lass mal sehen. Oh, der sieht aber lecker aus. Nein, Herr Doktor, Sie dürfen doch nicht... Oh, mein Bauch. Oh, ich leg mich mal hin. Herr Doktor, nein, Herr Doktor, Zotkast, uh, da da da da, Copyright, der Zotkast, uh, ja, das ist doch die schöne erste Episode. Oh, hast du das Video gesehen von dem Mann, der fast erschrickt wäre, wo dann das Heimlich-Manöver ausgeführt? Sagt man das auf Deutsch, Heimlich-Manöver? Genau das habe ich mich gefragt. Und das Heimlich-Manöver ist ja so ein Ding, jeder weiß, wie es aussieht. Um ehrlich zu sein, klingt es wie ein geheimes Manöver im Zweiten Weltkrieg, so wie er Staufen bei Gattentat. Ich dachte immer, das heimlich Manöver, und ich dachte auch, das Wort heimlich kommt daher, weil heimlich, als Kind, habe ich mir irgendwann gehört, heimlich Manöver. Also das ist, falls jemand sich verschluckt, dann packt man ihn von hinten so unter den Armen und dann ruckt man ihn so hoch. Dann reißt man das Bonbon raus. Richtig, dann reißt man so raus. Ich dachte immer, das Wort heimlich kommt vom heimlich Manöver. Und ich dachte, dass das heimlich Manöver Günther heimlich war, der damals heimlich versucht hat, Hitler umzubringen. Ja. Und weil er es so heimlich versucht hat, dachte ich, daher kommt das Wort heimlich. Aber glaubst du nicht, dass Heinrich heimlich, dass man den nicht als Ersten oft im Auge behält, wenn der irgendwie, was haben sie denn da für einen Koffer?
Nichts, kleines Geschenk für Adolf, sie meinen den Führer, ja ja, kleines Geschenk. Haben sie was im Auge, warum zwinkern sie? Herr Heimlich hat auch immer gepfiffen. Aber es ist eigentlich eine geniale Idee, es heimlich Manöver zu nennen, weil alle denken sich, was ist das für ein Manöver?
Kann ich das, hä? Nee, ist geheim. Nee, sag mal, mach mal. Nee, ist geheim. Und dadurch kannst du es dann weit verbreiten und jeder kennt es heimlich Manöver. Okay, jetzt ist es, wenn jemand vor dir erstickt und du ihm helfen musst, und du wissen musst, wie es geht, dann benutzt du das heimliche Manöverver. Du bist sofort enttäuscht. Ich sag's nicht. Ja, aber vor allem reicht es, das heimliche Manöver einmal gesehen zu haben, dass man es auch machen kann, oder ist da eine spezielle Technik dabei? Weil ich finde es ja immer respektabel, wenn dann Leute in so Situationen, gibt es ja diesen Bystander-Effekt, dass irgendjemand, keine Ahnung, liegt Blutend auf dem Boden und jeder denkt sich, ja, irgendjemand anders wird es ja schon machen, also helfe ich der Person nicht. Und beim heimlichen Manöver glaube ich so ähnlich, wenn einer so sich erstickt, denkt man sich, ist meine Kompetenz im heimlichen Manöver gross genug, dass es jetzt rechtfertigt, dass ich eingreife oder hat jemand anders noch eine höhere Kompetenz? Weil ich, ich weiß nicht, ob ich versuchen würde, das heimliche Manöver durchzuführen, weil ich weiß nur, wie es grob geht und wie es halt aussieht, aber nicht genau, was die Idee dahinter ist.
Bei mir hätte ich auch Angst, dass ich zu gross bin und es bei mir nicht funktioniert, wenn ich eher das Genick breche, weil ich ihn so hochreissen muss, den Menschen vor mir. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich würde es mir, glaube ich, zutrauen, das heimliche Manöver durchzuführen.
Wo genau müssen die Fäuste dahin, so unter den Brustkorb oder irgendwie sowas? Oder einfach einen schönen Schritt?
Ja, und dann, äh, ha, ha, ha, ha, Stengler, Stengler, das ist doch das heimliche Manöver.
Herrlich. Ne, guckt euch lieber mal an, damit es auch durchzuführen könnt.
Ja, aber man spuckt dann das aus, was man gerade gegessen hat, ne?
Ist man dann noch weiter?
Ja, als wäre nichts gewesen.
Als wäre nichts gewesen.
Bezahlt man das heimliche Manöver mit, ist das heimliche Manöver landes auf der Rechnung.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. das aus, was man gerade gegessen hat. Isst man dann noch weiter? Ja, als wäre nichts gewesen.
Bezahlt man das heimliche Manöver mit,
ist das heimliche Manöver landet es auf der Rechnung.
Das will ich wissen. Das wäre meine erste Frage.
Ich habe letztens gegessen,
verrückt, und ich habe eine Cherry-Tomate so wie sie ist runtergeschluckt.
Nicht reingebissen,
nicht gekaut. Bei völligem
Bewusstsein. Bei halbem Bewusstsein.
Es war ein Wirbelwind. Ich will wissen, sind deine Augen kurz aufgegangen? Ja, meine Augen sind kurz aufgegangen. Ja, ich habe es nicht mehr, ich habe es nicht mehr, ich habe es nicht mehr, ich habe es nicht mehr, ich habe es nicht mehr, ich habe eine Murmel ist das Beste, was man verschlucken kann. Glatte Oberflächen machen nichts kaputt. War längere Tage in meinem Organismus. Ja. wo er sich rausgeschossen hat, dass er seine Schwester erschossen hat. Es ist wirklich halt, dass wir immer meinen Kot untersuchen, meinen Stuhlgang untersuchen müssen, weil man... Mann, ich habe von der Woche erst über das Thema gesprochen. ...heraus wissen rum. Weil ich ja mal einen Teil meiner Spange verschluckt habe und dann auch danach suchen musste. Da muss man seinen Stuhl rumwurschteln. Furchtbar. Ja, eklig. Also Kinder sollten nichts verschlucken einfach. Nichts essen, gebt euren Kindern nichts zu essen. Wovon haben wir gerade gesprochen? Ob du schon mal im Krankenhaus warst, wollte ich wissen. Und ob du dann so lame Karten bekommen hast. Karten? Ja, was für Karten? Ich schaue mir tatsächlich mal ganz gerne die Karten an im Supermarkt, diese vorgefertigten Karten. so dieses Allesgute zum 5.
Und da gibt es ja teilweise die Basissachen, so Allesgute zum Geburtstag, sorry, dass ich gegen ein Auto gefahren bin, Entschuldigung, ich dachte, dein Kind hätte so ein Seil um den Hals, irgendwie sowas, ganz gute Sachen. Und dann gibt es halt so den Drüber, dass du hast, Herzlichen Glück zum 10. 20. 30. Geburtstag und dann drüber nochmal, dass es jedes einzelne Geburtstag hat, jeden einzelnen Jahreszahl noch Herzlichen Glück zum 8.30. Ja, und dann wird es irgendwann wirklich abstrus. Aber wer ist, also wenn du jetzt jemanden mehr magst, würdest du eher zu der Karte tendieren, die sehr spezifisch ist? Oder reicht bei einem sehr guten Freund auch vielleicht eher die Waagekarte, wo einfach nur xx den Geburtstag steht. Und das ist mein Punkt, weil ich musste letztens auch eine... Ne, du musst jetzt einen Punkt machen. Ne, ne, ne, weil ich muss... Ne, ne, darüber rede ich ja schon seit Jahren. Ich musste letztens eine Alles Gute zum Geburtstag Karte ausfüllen und vorne auf der Karte stand halt drauf, alles Gute zum Geburtstag. Und du machst die Karte auf und denkst dir, was soll ich denn jetzt noch hinschreiben? Was soll ich hier, du stellst auch dein Leben in Frage, warum bin ich hier, was soll ich noch beitragen, was soll ich noch, wie viel Welt funktioniert offensichtlich ohne mich. Ja, richtig, ich bin nicht nötig, aber du hast diese klackende, weisse Seite.. Der wird dir klar, bei solchen Momenten, die Welt dreht sich ohne dich weiter. Leute wünschen sich alles Gute zum Geburtstag. Ich habe Karten gefunden, da stand drauf, alles Gute zum 29. Geburtstag. Und du machst die Karte auf und da ist eine klaffende, weisse Fläche drin. Und denkst dir einfach, wie groß soll die noch schreiben? Alles G geburtstag schreiben wie gesagt ein weiteres jahr auf deinem buckel wieder erfolg für die zukunft ich weiß super schwierig deswegen sagt always start with a blank blank page always start with a blank page und dann kratzt ein bisschen mach mit weiß dierisse von Buchstaben drauf. Ja, ich finde, diese Karten machen es einem nicht einfach. Also die nehmen einem den besten Anfang weg. Total, deswegen für mich die Idee, möglichst Geburtstagskarten vorfertigen, wo fast noch nichts drauf ist. Also stell dir mal vor, eine komplett weisse Karte, wo du selber noch draufschreiben darfst, worum es geht, wo du selber was malen darfst.
Das erinnert mich an was. Meine Eltern haben immer gespendet für die Hand- und Fussmaler. Es sind Behinderte, die sich Geld damit verdienen, dass sie mit... Nee, warte mal, sorry, sorry.
Es sind nicht die Hand- und Fussmaler, Es sind die Nasen- und... Womit malen die denn? Womit malen die denn? Die Hals-Nasen-Ohren-Maler. Was haben die denn noch? Augen- und Fussmaler. Ich muss es googeln, das will ich nämlich jetzt echt richtig sagen. Die Nasen-Fuss- und Pinselmaler. Mund- und Fussmaler, sorry. Mund und Fuss. Nicht Hand und Fuss, weil die haben halt keine Arme, oder was?
Grosses Sorry geht raus an die Hand und Mund und Fussmaler. Also die malen mit Münden und Füssen, weil sie damit dann Geld verdienen, damit Künstler, weil die keine Hände haben. Und an die haben die immer gespendet, meine Eltern haben gespendet, auch an, vor allem an eine Behindertenwerkstatt. So, und die schicken dir dann, ich glaube, du spendest nicht an die Mund- und Fussmaler, ich glaube, du spendest an Behindertenvereine und die schicken dann von den Mund- und Fussmalern Kunstwerke. In dem Fall immer Postkarten, nicht auch mit originalen Kunstwerken drauf, sondern einfach Drucken von Hand und Mund- und Fuss malern gedönst. Und wir hatten halt sehr viele von diesen Postkarten und Karten von den Mund und Fuss malern. Und immer wenn ich jemandem, wenn ich der Tim hat den zwölften Geburtstag gefeiert, und dann wollte ich immer, und ich habe immer von meinen Freunden coole Karten bekommen. Da war ein Rennauto drauf. Oh, geil. Geil, da war Harry Potter drauf und alles Gute zum Geburtstag und so. Und ich dachte auch immer, ich wollte auch immer coole Karten geben, weil es war auch immer dieses, ja, wo er hat mir immer einen Zehner reingelegt und seinem Kumpel gegeben und so. Aber ich hatte bei jedem einzelnen Kumpel immer ein schönes Mund und Fuss mal gemeldet. Aber was ist das Motiv, das du für möglichst viele Zwecke verwenden kannst? Meine Aufgabe bestand immer einen Tag vor diesem Geburtstagsfeiern darin, meine Aufgabe, die ich mir selber gestellt habe, war, die möglichst am wenigsten peinliche Karte auszuwählen, die noch durchgeht als Geburtstagskarte. Ja. Weil das meiste sind einfach weirde Gemälde. Also genau wie, damit will ich nicht die Mund- und Fußmutter degradieren, sondern alle Gemälde auf Postkarten sind erstmal für Kinder unangemessen. Unangebracht, ja. Unangebracht, viele davon. Und das auch. Und da muss sich immer die blumigste Blumenwiese raussuchen, die am normalsten als alles gute Karte durchgeht und so. Also sowas ist am wenigsten abstrakt. Ich schubladenweise diese Karten und ich habe immer daran gesucht, wo ist der Rennwagen zu erkennen oder sowas. Was könnte als Harry Potter durchgehen? Ich glaube, ich habe wirklich in meinem Leben noch nie selber eine Karte gekauft. Ich kriege die immer so vorgelegt, man kennt sie im Büro oder so, jemand geht rum und alle unterschreiben, ich weiß auch nicht, was aus solchen Karten wird. Ich hab selber noch nie eine davon bekommen, das ist einfach so, das verschwindet im Äther einfach. Ich lebe mir vor, wie dann irgendwie so, es gibt dann immer so die gute Seele der Redaktion, die geht dann rum, unterschreibt und wenn sie alle Unterschriften hat, dann wirft sie es einfach weg. Voraus aus dem Fenster. Es ist einfach in so einer Feuerstelle einfach, zack, weg. alle ein gutes Gefühl geben. Ja, alle haben ein gutes Gefühl. Und vor allem die besten Geschenke sind ja die, die gar nicht ankommen. Weil man sagt, jetzt ist nicht angekommen und der andere sagt, passt schon, kein Problem. In Klammern wäre eh scheisse gewesen und ich muss mich dann irgendwie rumschlagen und irgendwie dann ein dummes T-Shirt tragen. Das Beste ist einfach, wenn alles virtuell einfach so ist. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Ja, diese Karten sind echt ein großes Mysterium. Ich weiß auch nicht, wer die designt und so. Und dann auch so dieses irgendwie, ich glaube so, wenn dieses Kinderkriegen anfängt irgendwie, wir sind noch nicht ganz in dem Alter, hier und da, und dann so ein Kind bekommen und dann ist ja auch weird, da gibt es keinen Gruß, da gibt es nicht irgendwie ein gut Kind oder irgendwie frohes Wickeln oder irgendwie sowas. Da hast du dann diese peinlichen Karten, wo dann so ein kleiner Frosch irgendwie dann drauf ist und dann schickst du die. Dann bist du, glaube ich, heilfroh, dass es diese Karten gibt. Ja, vor allem, da frage ich mich immer, an wen schickst du denn dann diese Karten? Also suchst du ein kindliches Motiv für einen kleinen Babyfrosch oder ein kleines Gummibärchen oder machst du es an die Eltern? Und dann irgendwie so ein schönes Mund- und Fussmaler Gemäldelde. Was was beiden gefällt, Clara und Ben, beide müssen Spaß an der Karte haben. Ben ist großer Heavy-Metal-Fan, Clara mag, ist halt auch viel im Ausland unterwegs. Ist auch da, ist auch dabei. Ich kenne halt eher mehr Ben als Clara. Das habe ich mir schon gedacht. Ich bin halt mit ihm viel auf Metal-Konzerten unterwegs. Clara spricht auch nicht gut über dich. Ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich habe die auch erst einmal kennengelernt. Aber du sprichst auch nicht gut über Clara, von daher passt sie ja. Ja, es gibt ja auch immer so einen Freund, wo man noch nie die Freundin getroffen hat, wo man so 50, 50, also 50 Prozent Vampir, 50 Prozent existiert nicht. 50 Prozent berühmt. 50, oh ja,% waren extrem berühmt. Es ist Venus Williams. Sorry? Ja, meine Freundin ist Venus Williams. Das sagst du jetzt? Ich wollte es nicht sagen, weil wir nicht wussten, wie es am Anfang läuft. Wir haben uns am Anfang halt ab und zu getroffen und jetzt ist es halt was Festes. Die Venus Williams! Ja, ich habe jetzt halt den Punkt verpasst, an dem ich... Sagt man Venus Williams oder Venus Williams? Venus Williams, nicht Venus Williams, auf gar keinen Fall. Venus Williams. So, und da fängt es schon an, dass jetzt von dir ein dummer Gag wiederkommt, dass du das einfach nicht ernst nehmen kannst, dass ich die beste Tennisspielerin der Welt als Volker habe. Warum hast du dich für Venus entschieden, nicht für Serena? Ich ich dachte, es ist Serena. So, und jetzt, okay, ja, es ist nicht die beste Situation, gebe ich zu. Und die ersten Treffen waren ... Moment, wärst du lieber mit Serena zusammen als mit Venus Williams? Das spielt doch jetzt keine Rolle. Venus und ich sind sehr glücklich zusammen, und wenn sie gleich reinkommt, will ich nicht, dass da irgendeine dumme Sprüche kommen. Was? Gleich kommt Venus Williams durch diese ... Ja, aber jetzt ruhig dich, mein Gott, die erlebt das jeden Tag. Wer ist die Erfolgreiche, Venus oder Serena? Serena ist ein bisschen erfolgreich. Das ist aber auch nicht so wichtig. Deswegen wolltest du mit Serena eher abhängen. Na, Quatsch, das hat doch jetzt überhaupt nichts damit zu tun. Ich dachte einfach, so, ich bin mit Venus zusammen und wir verstehen uns auch viel besser. Und jetzt die ganzen Scheiss-Planetengags. Sp Spar deine Scheiss-Planeten-Gags, okay? Ich mach keine Planeten-Gags. Kein einzigen Planeten-Gag. Nein, ich find's toll, dass du jemanden hast. Du hast lange jemanden gesucht. Ich find's toll, dass du jemanden hast. Tennisarm, hehehe, ha ha ha. Lass es einfach, okay? Okay, gut. Man kann bei dir nie irgendwie nur mal eine Freundin vorbeibringen, weil bei dir immer so dumme Sprüche kommen. Nein, nein, nein, das ist alles cool, das ist alles cool. Ich meine, es ist ja schön, dass du das auch redest, wie Venus Williams jetzt hier hilft, jetzt nicht der Situation, aber... So, okay, ich will kein einziges Wort haben. Ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt. Ich will kein einziges Wort. Sie ist eine ganz normale Frau. Ich weiß nicht, vergiss einfach, dass sie Venus Williams ist. Ich kenne die Regeln von Tennis nicht mehr, ich weiß nicht, wovon ich hier reden soll. Komm rein, Schatz! Ah, da bist du ja. Hallo! Ha- hallo! Ha, Schatz, guck mal, und das ist mein alter Schuhfreund, Hugo, Hugo, Wienes, Wienes, Hugo. Wo ist denn Ihre Schwester Merkur? So, ich gehe. Er wollte eh lieber mit Serena abhängen. Das habe ich dir im Vertrauen, was? Bam bam bam. Aus dem Auto rief er noch, das habe ich dir im Vertrauen, erzielt. Was? Es kann manchmal schwierig sein, es kann manchmal schwierig sein. Ja, aber ja, nee, aber wirklich diese Karten verwirren mich aufs Ewigsten und vor allem denn irgendwann kommen ja auch diese Andachtskarten. Also wenn jemand tot ist und dann schreibst du dann so eine Karte, sorry, sorry, ich war's nicht. Machen wir da einen Gag? Das ist das Positivste, was man sagen kann. Also ich war's ja nicht. Also ich habe ja nichts, kann ja da nicht. Ehrlich gesagt, lass uns mal ein bisschen tiefer blicken. Ich habe mich in einem Fall sehr konkret über diese Karten gefreut. Ja? Ja, ich dachte immer, die wären Bullshit. Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe mein Leben lang, dachte ich mit meiner blöden, zynischen Kackart, diese Andenk-Karten, Beileidsbegründungen sind uncool. Mega. Du freust dich, wenn ein Familienmitglied stirbt, freust du dich natürlich narzisstisch darauf, dass der Berg riesig ist. Je grösser der Berg, desto besser fühlst du dich. Das Problem ist, ich habe tatsächlich, man erwartet ja eigentlich immer, diese Karten sind ja eigentlich immer nur der Überbringer von Geld. Und denkst du dir, du machst die Karte auf und da fällt ein Schein. In manchen war auch Geld drin. So, und dann denkst du dir, wenn jetzt jemand, und ich wüsste nicht, erstens, ob man jemandem Geld gibt, wenn ein Familienmitglied verstorben ist, und wenn ja, wie viel? Eher nicht. Ein Fünfer? Nee, eher nicht. Ein schöner Fünfer? Eher nicht, wenn dann mehr, aber eher nicht, manchmal für Blumen legen die was dabei. Aber in dem konkreten Fall kamen sehr viele Karten, ich habe mich über ihr gefreut, und das Geilste war immer, wenn Leute viel geschrieben haben. Was aber dann wieder um die anderen Karten schlechter aussehen lässt. Ja, steht schon mein Beileid, steht nur vorne drauf und dann schreiben die nochmal rein mein Beileid und man denkt, wie viel, wie viel, wie viel, wie viel Beileid kannst du haben? Ja. Und dann guckst du, versuchst du, die Unterschrift zu entziffern, Frank, von dem ich noch nie gehört habe, wie viel Beileid hast du, Frank? Und es gibt auch immer den einen Deppen, der die Karte falschrum aufmacht und sie falschrum beschriftet.
Du machst es auf und musst dann so auf den Kopf so, was? Du bist einfach ein Vollidiot.
Oder manche, man kann manchmal handgeschriebene Zettel und man denkt, ja.
Also wirklich, man freut sich wirklich unironisch über Beileid zu kundigen. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass du auch eine unironische Phase hast.
Nee, in dem Moment habe ich mich, ich habe auch in Zeiten der Trauer, habe ich auch Comedy gemacht.
Ja? Weiter auf die Bühne, oder was?
Ich bin weiter auf die Bühne gegangen und habe auch zynische Gags über diese Karten gemacht.
Es entstehen, können wir aber irgendwann mal in Ruhe darüber reden, aber es stehen so lustige Entscheidungen an wie was für Texte schreibt
man auf die
Einladung zur Beerdigung zum Beispiel.
Weil es ist Tradition, dass man so Gedichte
berühmte drausschreibt und so.
Und ich dachte irgendwann, Alter,
keine Ahnung, man will ja dem Toten
auch irgendwie gerecht werden
und so und dann kommt dann
die Frau kommt dann mit so Standardtexten um die Ecke,
wo dann so, kam dann in dem Fall mit so Engeln und Gott und Kram und man denkt die ganze Zeit, das passt alles nicht und so. Und dann denkt man schon über Gags nach, vor allem wenn man halt auch Comedy macht, so beruflich, denkt man auch die ganze Zeit, die ganze Zeit rattert das und man denkt, man könnte so viel. Das ganze Feld der Beerdigung ist open for Gags. Ja. Ich glaube, da sind so viele Möglichkeiten entstanden in diesem paar Wochen. Das ist schon interessant. Ich glaube auch, dass Religion primär dadurch entstanden ist, dass Leute nicht genau wussten, was man in solchen Situationen sagen soll. Und dann dieses Ja, sie schaut vom Himmel zu. Ja. Die ganze Zeit jetzt. Ab jetzt, 24, 7. Ab jetzt.
Hat sie denn die Möglichkeit, was anderes zu machen?
Selbst wenn sie nicht mehr gucken will, guckt sie auch runter?
Muss sie gucken?
Schaut sie sich nicht erst mal im Himmel ein bisschen um?
So, ah, hier, Billardtisch.
Muss sie jetzt runterstarren?
Werden ihre Augen so offen gehalten?
Eigentlich ist der Himmel eine furchtbare Vorstellung.
Engel! Nee, Himmel, im Himmel zu sein, ist für mich eine furchtbare Vorstellung, weil du kannst ja dann nicht mehr sterben ab dem Punkt. Das war es ja dann erst mal. Und ich meine, das Leben ist ja schon dadurch irgendwie interessant, dass man stirbt. Man weiß, ja, ich muss jetzt schon ein bisschen was voran machen, ich muss was erleben, weil du stirbst halt irgendwann. Und im Himmel ist es ja wirklich furchtbar, weil du denkst dir, ja, mach ich morgen, ja, mach ich morgen, ja, mach ich im nächsten Jahrtausend, mach ich irgendwann und dann irgendwann hat ja nichts mehr irgendwie einen Wert. Also das ist ja fast, also wirklich fast eine Horrorvorstellung, irgendwo zu sein, wo du weißt, ich komme hier nie wieder raus. Nie wieder. Aber es ist ja alles perfekt. Ja, aber was ist perfekt, wenn es keinen Kontrast mehr hast? Aber alles ist perfekt. Ja, aber ist ja dann schon nicht alles perfekt. Es muss ja Abstufungen geben. Ist alles perfekt. Und das heißt, dass es auch schlechte Sachen gibt, damit das Perfekte perfekt ist. Ach so. Das ist das perfekte Leben. Also es gibt auch dann Tod und Krieg und Verderben, damit du dann sagst, oh, jetzt ist der Scheiss zum Glück vorbei, dass du die freuen kannst. Aber wem passiert der dann, das frage ich mich, sind das dann Statisten, so Schauspieler und sind die schon gestorben oder sind das sogar, das ist mein Tipp, die Leute aus der Hölle müssen für die Leute im Himmel nämlich so weirde Vorführungen geben, damit die wirklich das perfekte Leben haben. Im Himmel hätte ich gerne einen Diener. Wer ist der Diener? Das muss eigentlich der Engel machen. Wenn es für mich perfekt ist, will ich einen Diener. Dann sagen die, ja, okay. Und wer ist dann der Diener? Engel? Aber Engel sind doch auch, sind die tot? Mal ganz kurz, hier ist ja alles perfekt, ne? Oder? Hier ist alles perfekt. Ja. Und mir wird dir der Wünsch erfüllt, mehr oder weniger. Jetzt ist es so, mein Onkel Paul, der war, ich sag mal, zu Lebzeiten nicht der Ehrlichste. Also der hat hier und da, hat er was angestellt. Der ist jetzt leider in der Hölle. Ich sehe gerade, genau, der ist in der Hölle gelandet. Richtig, richtig. Aber ist alles gut gelaufen. Genau, aber könnt ihr den hier hochholen, zu mir? Um was zu tun? Damit er hier ist. Haben wir schon einen Antrag gestellt in der Hinsicht? Wie, das wollte ich jetzt gerade machen. Ich könnte den holen, weil eigentlich, oder könnt ihr nicht einfach alle aus der Hölle hier hoch holen, weil es ist mein Wunsch. Und für mich wäre der Himmel halt perfekt, wenn halt alle, die jetzt in der Hölle sind, eher im Himmel wären. Ich muss ganz kurz telefonieren. Klar, ich habe Zeit. Einfach, nehmen Sie sich einen Kaffee, dann ist ein Nespresso. Kein Problem, ich weiß, perfekte Temperaturen nebenbei, perfekt. Die perfekte Nespresso, wussten Sie,, dass die perfekte Kassel-Profe-Maschine Nespresso ist? Ich nicht. Naja, mal bedienen Sie sich einfach. Ich gehe kurz raus. Dieser Nespresso-Caffee ist ja wirklich schmackhaft. Da muss ich das nicht mal betonen. Nochmal ganz kurz wegen meinem Wunsch. Ich muss ganz kurz telefonieren. Dude, dude. Bei Genghis Khan, der wäre halt auch mal...
Bitte, ganz kurz.
Mit dem will ich auch gerne mal...
Ich muss gerade jemanden anrufen.
Auch in der Hölle leider.
Können wir die nicht alle hochholen?
Gott, ja, Gott, Gott, hallo, Gott?
Hi, ja, ähm, ich hab, hier hat's jemand herausgefunden.
Ja, jemand hat herausgefunden, dass das alles nicht funktioniert.
Ja, er hat die Frage gestellt.
Mhm. Ja, das Paradoxon, ja. Was mache ich denn jetzt? Ich dachte, es passiert in den ersten tausend Jahren nicht. Ganz kurz, weil Paul, es wäre cool, wenn er heute noch, weil die Reise ist ja... Okay, ich muss ihn gerade telefonieren. Okay, hört man nicht oft von Engeln, aber... Wie, ich soll ihn umbringen? Eigentlich wäre es perfekter, wenn ich nicht umgebracht werden würde. Er hört auch die ganze Zeit zu gerade, deshalb werden die so clever. Okay, alles klar. Gut, danke, ciao Gott. Also, wie schaut es aus? Schön langsam ist das nicht mehr so perfekt für mich hier oben. Okay, ja, ich ... Irgendwie ist es nicht mehr so perfekt gerade. Moment mal, was ist das? Es tut mir sehr leid, aber Sie sind dahinter gekommen. Sie haben alles gelöst. Alles gelöst, ja. Es ist nicht alles perfekt, okay? Für mich auch gerade nicht. Ja, ich bin super gestresst gerade. Sie machen mir den Himmel gerade zur Hölle. Es ist nicht für jeden perfekt, okay? Das ist halt eine leere Versprechung gewesen, so ein Wahlkampfversprechen. Sie hätten sich ja auch für Buddhismus entschieden können, haben sie nicht, weil es war ein gutes Wahlkampfversprechen. Woher weißt du eigentlich, dass du im Himmel bist? Vielleicht ist das dir deine ganz persönliche Hölle. Nein, nein, oh Satan, nein, ach komm! Was auch wie ich bin!
Was auch wie ich bin!
Nein!
Ach komm!
Die Hufe haben dich verraten.
Ich weiß, die sind sehr, sehr schwer. Der Dreizack, der an einer Wand lehnt.
Ja, mein Gott, ey.
Dreizack.
Ein schöner Dreizack.
Werbung.
Wusstest du, dass LTE 4G ist? Wie kommen sie in meine Wohnung? Ich sag nur. Werbung 5G, das kann ja nicht so schwer sein. 5G ist die atemberaubende neue Geschwindigkeit, die schon an manchen Orten in Deutschland empfangbar ist. Und ihr könnt es auch erleben mit dem Vodafone Gigacube, den ihr einfach zu Hause in eure Steckdose steckt, vorausgesetzt ihr habt einen Handyempfang und einen Mobilfunkvertrag. Moment mal, du willst mir erzählen, ich kaufe dann diesen Vodafone Gigacube SIM-Karte rein, kein Techniker, nicht irgendwie rumgefummelt, Termin gefangen, so ich kann einfach direkt anfangen zu surfen. Ja, vorausgesetzt, du hast einen Mobilfunkvertrag. Und du bist an einem Ort, wo die 5G verfügbar ist. Ansonsten schaffst du ein bisschen langsamer, aber an 5G-Orten kannst du auch 5G surfen. Und wenn du jetzt Campen bist, du warst ja erst Campen, hattest du da Internetempfang? Überhaupt nicht. Nee, gar nicht. Und stell dir mal vor, du hast einen Giga-Cube mitge einen Vodafone Gigacube, dann hättest du dir einfach loszuhelfen können. Krass. Fun, fun, fun, bedeutet das. Wenn ihr mehr Informationen wollt, geht einfach auf www.vodafone.de slash gigacube und checkt es aus. Und jetzt viel Spaß mit den beiden Wilden vom Podcast UFO, wenn die Folge weitergeht. Und eurem Vodafone Gigacube. Werbung. Ach ja. Man kann eigentlich so im mittelalter wenn du so ich meine es gab ja auch custom ritter so ne also ich meine custom ritter wir haben ja die die ritterrüstung gesehen in metropolitan und es gab doch bestimmt auch leute die gesagt haben so nee gib mir mal so ein schwert wo so drei klingen dran sind also einfach mal so mit Schmied so... Dummwinschi hat auch gesagt, das Schwert geht in alle Richtungen. Genau. Und es ist nicht nur an der scharfen Seite scharf, sondern auch an der stumpfen. Es ist auch am Griff scharf. Es ist überall scharf. Falls mir jemand das Schwert klaut, dass er sich selber wehtut. Hand ab. Und dann trage ich so eine grosse, grosse Handschuhe, die aber auch super scharf sind, in alle Richtungen. Und dann hast du irgendwie so eine grosse Schlacht. Mit Kanonen auch drauf. Ja, grosse Schlacht Hastings, weil die Ritter sehen sich ja das Jahr über nicht. Die telefonieren ja nicht. Und dann kommst du zur Schlacht von Hastings und denkst, Alter, ich hab mir so, na, das ist dreifach Schwert. Und dann kommst du an und alle denken sich, was ist das denn? Und das ist ein Dreizack-Ding. Ja. Und alle so, was für ein Vollidiot und so, wie, ich dachte, das ist geil. Aber ganz kurz, angenommen, es bricht jetzt Krieg aus gegen Frankreich und Frankreich hat plötzlich diese Armee aus fliegenden Ironman-Menschen. Ja. Sorry, hast du das bitte gesehen? Wie? Das Flugbord, was Frankreich vorgestellt hat? Ja, ja. Bitte was? Aber haben wir aber schon geredet eigentlich? Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube nicht. heraus es war wirklich ein spider-man-moment wirklich wo wirklich so der green goblin es war ein ding rum fliegt was geht denn jetzt es war exakt der green goblin eine einleitung was ist passiert und zwar es gab nationalfeiertag in frankreich und damit zur ehren des tages wird dann immer gibt es eine militparade, wo auch die neuesten Sachen vorgestellt werden.
Unter anderem dieses Mal viel Kram, Zeugs, Gedöns und dann kamen Leute in Uniformen vorbei, Panzern und so ein Scheiß. Auch alle da. Trump, Angela Merkel, Christine Lagarde, ich weiß nicht, warum sie nicht mehr als Dritte eigentlich von ist, alle waren da. Und dann dacht man schon fast, ja okay, typischer Nationalfeiertag, bis am Horizont plötzlich etwas erschien, was diesen Tag in die Geschichtsbuch eingehen lassen wird, weil es kam der Green Goblin, es kam der Silver Surfer, es kam einer, ein Mann mit einem Maschinengewehr in der einen Seite, in der einen Hand, und in der anderen Hand so ein Joystick, der auf einem Flying Board geflogen ist, herumgeflogen ist, ultraschnell.
Es gibt Videos von denen, die nicht gezeigt wurden an dem Tag, wo er einem Schnellboot hinterher fährt.
Die sind ultraschnell, ultraschnell, so Ironman-artig, fliegen die rum, supergeile Präzision, in der einen Hand ist das eine Waffe die ganze Zeit.
Also stell dir mal vor, das ist ein Attentat in Frankreich und dann kommen diese
Dinger da angeflogen.
Holy shit!
Ich würde mich nicht mehr trauen, jetzt in Frankreich einen Attentat zu begehen.
Aber zeigen die das, um es zu verkaufen
oder um anderen Angst zu machen?
Anzugeben, Angst zu machen.
Um anzugeben einfach. Ich fand es mega geil.
Bis rauskam, dass der Typ
der Gründer der Firma ist, der
geflogen ist und der einzige ist, der das Ding fliegen kann. Und man auch denkt so, wenn man den abschiesst, ja, das war unsere Flying-Board-Armee, das waren alle. Und man denkt so, ja, du und welche Armee, nee, ich bin's alleine, ich bin die Flying-Board-Armee. Aber wie schwer kann es denn zu fahren sein? Ich fände es so lustig, die Vorstellung, dass sie gerade, dass da kam ja diese Armee angelaufen, dann kam ja mal so, da kam das fünfte Bataillon angelaufen und dann kam er angefangen und man dachte, sehr geil, das ist der Prototyp oder wahrscheinlich oder so. Nee, das ist der Einzige, das ist der Einzige, den es gibt. Der muss es richten, wenn die Deutschen wiederkommen, irgendwie schön durch die Ardennen mal wieder, fuck man, ey, zum dritten Mal, Alter. Der ist der guy. Und dann einfach so, ey, hast du kurz Zeit? Ja, wir dachten, das wäre ein Sample, aber das ist die Ardennen mal wieder fuck der muss zum dritten mal und dann einfach so er hast du kurz Zeit ja wir dachten das wäre ein Sample aber das ist die Armee es ist aber die haben die gesamte Flying-Board-Armee vorgestellt aber der wirft dann auch so grüne Granaten oder was grüne Granaten auch dieses genau und dann kommt auch die Theme die Alan Silvestri vorher cool schreibt es ist einfach Green Goblin es ist einfach Green Goblin fantastisch fand ich ganz toll es sah wirklich beeend aus. Im Endeffekt einfach eine Drohne, diese Quadrokopter, auf dem man steht. Ich denke mir auch, warum macht man einfach eine Drohne? Eine grosse Drohne. Ist das nicht besser ohne Mensch? Ja, wahrscheinlich besser. Weil der Mensch wird müde und ich muss mich kurz hinlegen. Ja, der Mensch muss er nicht mehr hinlegen. Und die Drohne einfach zzzzzz. Ich habe auch viele Hinweise bekommen zum Thema Drogen im Dritten Reich. Vielen Dank für die ganzen Buchempfehlungen. Ich habe leider vergessen, wie der Buchtitel heißt, aber ich habe eins bestellt und werde es mir durchlesen. Ich habe nur einen Lager bekommen und die ging ungefähr so. Ja, glaub nicht, was dein Nazi-Oper dir gesagt hat. Wahrscheinlich war er mehr Nazi als du denkst und ist wahrscheinlich nicht nur den Funkwagen gefahren.
Dann glaube ich, der letzte Satz war in Klammern, äh in Anführungszeichen, sie sind ja alle nur den Funkwagen gefahren. Okay, wow. Das ist mir auch gut. Ja, mein Opa ist tot, ich weiß nicht genau, wie ich... Du, wir sind auch mit 20.000 Funkwagen damals nach Russland gefahren. Angelogen, viele Funkwelgen, wir waren. Wir wollten, dachte ich immer wir auch, eine schöne Verbindung, schöne Funkverbindung. Aber Funkwagen, da war schon auch an dem Wagen so ein Rohr dran. Dachte ich mir auch so, ist am Funkwagen ist er auch eine Knarre. Weil ich meine, Panzer hat auch Funk. Liegt da auch eine, ist ein,... Ist Funkwagen einfach ein Euphemismus für Panzer? Ich glaube schon. Weil ich weiß nicht... Warte mal, naja, okay, kann schon sein. Ich bin so ein Rüsselwagen gefahren. Was wirst du das machen? So ein Waschwagen gefahren. So ein Rüsselwagen mit so einem Rüsselfond dran. Wir haben immer Rüsselwagen, haben wir gesagt. Panzerschokolade zu Crystal Meth und Rüsselwagen zu Panzer gesagt. Ich bin Rüsselwagen gefahren und habe auf Leute geworfen. Ja, und habe Leute angetrötet. Die meisten der Euphemismen. Und die Juden haben wir angepustet. Ja. Muss ich auch mal die Wochenschau anschauen, wie das da verkauft wurde eigentlich. Ja. Es gibt ja einige Folgen Wochenschau tatsächlich auf YouTube, sehr interessant sich das anzuschauen. Die wurden ja im Kino immer gezeigt, im Kino bevor der Film angeht, alle mussten sich das anschauen. Mit Endcredits und Production Logos. Ach und halt wirklich so die Nachrichten einfach, aber da Fernsehen noch nicht so verbreitet werden, haben wir es im Kino angeguckt. Popcorn? Und halt immer so super schnell alles Popcorn auch dabei. Und ich denke mir so, ich habe die Popcorn schon während der Wochenschau gesehen. Gegessen einfach so. Und es ist einfach total abgefahren, wie die das alles darstellen. Moment, vorm Film war das dann? Vorm Film hat man die Wochenschau gesehen, ja. Sieht doch noch mega runter. Nee, das waren ja keine schlechte Nachrichten in der Wochenschau, das kannst du sicher sein. Da kannst du sagen, ja, uns ist ein Panzer ins Wasser gefallen, wir Dussel, sorry, ein Rüsselwagen ist in Steigenrad, da war so ein kleiner Sieg, ist da reingeplumpst und dann plopp, und da haben wir einen Panzer haben wir verloren, aber ansonsten, und wir haben irgendwie so eine Armee haben wir den Kontakt kurz verloren, aber das ist halt oft so. Jetzt geht der Film los. Bei Tim und Struppi zwei. Viel Spaß mit, welcher Film kommt aus der Zeit? Simpsons, der Film. Simpsons, ja, Simpsons läuft schon lange. Läuft schon sehr lange. Nee, der Hitler-junge Quecks, der berühmte Film. Jetzt kommt ja ein neuer Film raus, von diesem, der auch What We Do in the Shadows gemacht hat. Nicht von Teika, aber wirklich? Ja, doch, Comedy aus dem Dritten Reich. Von so einem jungen Hitlerjugend-Jungen, dessen imaginärer Freund Hitler ist. Das ist eine Comedy, straight Comedy. Aber halt auch wirklich so mit Kindersoldaten kämpfen und wer ist der coolste in der Truppe. Coole Setting, natürlich ultra deprimierend, Kindersoldaten sind das Schlimmste, was man sich vorstellen kann, aber halt die untereinander halt auch so, wie die halt dann alle so, oh, der ist der Coole, oh, der traut sich nicht, halt so eine Schulgeschichte, aber halt zur schlechtest möglichen Zeit, aber das war halt auch eine Art von Kindheit. Coming of age. Deswegen Coming of age, ja. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, Stephen Merchant spielt auch
eine kleine Rolle. Wahrscheinlich eine grosse
bei ihm.
Diese grossen Gags, die hast
du einfach alle in der Westentasche.
Merchant, Merchant, wahrscheinlich spielst du eine grosse Rolle, oder?
Dad-Joke war das.
Du hast einfach alle
drin. Du hast einfach alle drin.
Ich trage keine Unterhose. Ist dir das aufgefallen?
Ich wünsche, dass es nicht gesagt. Weil, jetzt habe ich Bedürfnis, hinzugucken? Ne, ne, ne. Ich will nicht hingucken. Guck ruhig hin. Nein! Guck ruhig hin. Nein! Aber ich denke mir so, ich dachte mir so, wenn es heiß ist, viele Leute denken ja so, oh, es wird heiß, also ziehe ich weniger Kleidung an und fangen oben an. Ich ziehe die Jacke aus. Shirt aus. Aber ich denke mir, nee, fang unten an. Das Erste, was wegfällt, ist die Unterwäsche. Und schon ist es kühler, ohne dass du jetzt irgendwie deine Kleidung gross ändern musst. Ich muss meine Regel revidieren. Die grosse Revision. Die grosse Revision. Die grosse Revision. Die grosse Revision. Die grosse Revision. Die grosse Revision. Die grosse Revision. Die grosse Revision. Die grosse Revision. Warum haben die damals in diesen Nazifirmen auch immer so gesprochen? Das war mit Schneid. Die grosse Re-ge-re-vision. Immer übersteuert auch. Re-ge-re-vision. Ja, was ist es denn? Naja, die Ruckel-re-vision. Re-vision. Korrektur. Wie heißt es in der Zeitung immer? Sorry. Gegendarstellung. Gegendarstellung, richtig. Ist meine grosse Regel zu sagen, ab 21 Grad ist kurze Hosenzeit. Ist mittlerweile zu kalt.
Es wird zu häufig die 21-Grad-Grenze überschritten.
Deswegen würde ich jetzt hochsetzen auf 23 Grad.
Alles klar, dann müssen wir die kompletten Flyer nochmal umschreiben.
Ja, gut, damit machen wir das halt.
Alle Flyer werden umgeschrieben.
Ist okay.
Sorry, es gibt eine grandiose Geschichte von Mark Maron. Der war irgendwie auf so einem Comedy-Festival oder sowas. Und dann haben die Flyer gedruckt, tausend Flyer gedruckt. Und dann haben die tausend Flyer gedruckt und dann war das Datum falsch. Und ich dachte, fuck, na gut, müssen wir nochmal die Flyer drucken. Und dann haben sie nochmal die Flyer gedruckt und das Datum war wieder falsch. Und dann dachte ich, okay, fuck, wir haben langsam kein Geld mehr, wir können es uns nicht leisten, die Flyer nochmal zu drucken. Also lass uns einfach jetzt nur Aufkleber drucken mit dem neuen Datum drauf, dass wir immer nur das Datum überkleben, dann können wir die Flyer noch nutzen. Haben sie diese Aufkleber gedrückt, dann ist das Datum mal wieder falsch. Auf den Aufkleber. Warum? Ich finde das so gut, dass ich einfach ein bisschen was erlassen lasse. Oder versuche ich einfach an diesem Tag das zu machen. Ich finde das so gut. Ab welchem Punkt sagt man einfach, wisst ihr was, wir sagen einfach alles ab. Oder wir treten einfach an dem anderen Datum auf, können wir das Festival verschieben. Wir haben drei verschiedene Daten jetzt. Ich finde, das ist eine die Vorstellung, denselben Fehler dreimal zu machen.
Vor allem den Fehler auch noch dann zu machen, wenn der Zweck nur der ist, den Fehler zu korrigieren, bei den Stickern. Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Oh, herrlich, herrlich. Aber du sagst 23 Grad, kurze Hosen. 23 Grad ist, ob jetzt kurze Hosenzeit, 23 Grad, ja. Wir müssen es vielleicht nochmal hochsetzen, noch 24 Grad, bin ich offen für Vorschläge. Bleibt unsere Mode eigentlich jetzt dieselbe, weil es wird ja immer wärmer jetzt, Klimawandel, oder driftet das alles so zurück? Weil sonst hatte man so Wintermode, dass man sagt, Herbstmode ist jetzt die neue Wintermode und die neue Sommermode wird zur Frühlingsmode. Also alles rückt eine Stufe höher, weil es immer eine Stufe wärmer ist. Genau, leider ist es der Winter, die Sommermode, was problematisch ist, weil wir ja, aber gibt's dann, ich verstehe schon, es rückt alles eins nach vorne und gibt's dann eine neue Mode obendrauf, dass man dann wirklich so nochmal ultrawarm, so wirklich so ganz so löchrige T-Shirts und gar und irgendwie dann wirklich oh, tatsächlich habe ich jetzt schon ich habe wieder neue Shirts bestellt, weil es gibt nämlich eine Seite, wo man seine Größe, sein Gewicht, Schuhgröße eingeben kann und dann berechnen die, dann berechnen die dein perfektes Shirt. Dann berechnen sie, wie dein T-Shirt in 50 Jahren aussieht. Ja. Wie dein verwaschen und alt ist. Ja, wow, die Technik. Du kannst dann dein perfekt passendes Shirt bestellen und du hast keinen nervigen Print drauf und sowas und einfach ein cooles Shirt. Was hast du gegen Print? Dein nerviges Print guckt mich die ganze Zeit weird an. Manche Prints sind gut, aber ich hätte gerne, ich bin Fan von reinen Shirts. Reinen Shirts, weissen, reinen Shirts. Nimm die Hand runter. Und das ist halt geil da und das können die machen. Und da gibt es jetzt die Möglichkeit auszuwählen, normales weisses Shirt oder leichtes Sommershirt. Das heißt, da wird mittlerweile offensichtlich schon unterschieden zwischen es wird so ultraheiss, Leute, ganz weicher, feiner Stoff, der einfach nur noch aufliegt, wie so eine Haut. Das andere ist halt klassischer dickerer T-Shirt-Stoff. Aber was ist das Limit? Was ist die leichteste, sommerlichste Kleidung, die man sich vorstellen kann. Was? Wie heißt nochmal das, was Frodo anhat?
Mitril.
Gut, aber er ist auch heiß.
Also er hat geschwitzt, ey.
Mitril ist heiß.
Heiß kurz ausziehen.
Hat Mitril eine so eine Eigenschaft?
Mitril ist nur leicht.
Mitril ist ja nur leicht.
Wann hat Georg aufgehört zu atmen eigentlich?
Georg atmet nicht mehr.
Georg krächzt in der Ecke.
Georg wurde erwürgt einfach. Die hatten eine lange Plakatkampagne. Georg atmet nicht mehr. Die atmet nicht mehr Georgs krächzt in der Ecke Georgs wurde erwürgt einfach die hatten eine lange Plakatkampagne Georgs atmet nicht mehr die atmet nicht mehr nee nee weil es Quatsch ist vielleicht brauchen wir Georgs wir brauchen so Georgs T-Shirts oder so ja aber meinst du unser ganzes dass man einfach dann komplett dass es dann normal ist dass man oben ohne unterwegs ist das glaube ich nicht meinst du nicht oh das ist spannend auch wegen der Gender-Thematik. Dürfen Frauen oben oben rumlaufen, dürfen eher Männer oben rumlaufen.
Auch Männer dürfen einfach so oben rumlaufen in der Straße.
Ja.
Frauen?
Oder gilt das schon als Erregung öffentlichen Eingernis?
Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen lockerer, oder?
Ich glaube, das ist mittlerweile schon ...
Gibt es da nicht irgendein Gesetzesding, dass man sagt, ja, passt schon?
Finde ich gut.
Passt schon?
Passt schon.
Das Passt schon-Gesetz. Man wurde viel gekichert bei der Verlesung dieses Gesetzes, aber dass man sagt, ja, passt schon. Finde ich gut. Passt schon? Passt schon. Das Passt-Show-Gesetz.
Man wurde viel gekichert bei der Verlesung dieses Gesetzes, aber
da muss man durch.
Warum kichern Sie jetzt? Da muss man durch.
Gut, ich wiederhole es noch mal.
Artikel 25, die Freizeit des Menschen
wird ab sofort geändert.
Passt schon.
Passt schon. Was ist daran denn lust, passt show, punkt. Raus damit, passt show, oder, können Sie jetzt, lassen Sie diese Geräusche bitte, hey, aua, haben Sie mich gerade geschlagen mit Ihrem Richterhammer, der ist dazu da, um Ruhe zu machen. Au, au, der tut ja richtig, au, der tut ja richtig, das ist eine richtig gute Waffe. Au, Moment mal, da sagen Sie was. Oh, sie sind ja Richter, sie sind viel zu mächtig plötzlich, die Gerichte haben zu viel Macht plötzlich.
Wissen Sie was, man darf ja Menschen einen nicht verletzen.
Wissen Sie, wie ich das Gesetzbuch hier, das Gesetzbuch hier, ist schwer das Gesetzbuch. Wissen Sie, wie ich das in dem Artikel jetzt auch nenne? Man darf andere nicht verletzen. Ja. Passt schon. Außer mit dem Hämmerchen, mit dem kleinen Richterhämmerchen. Ich verstehe das. Hast du genau verstanden, wie Gesetze entstehen? Null. Einen genauen Prozess? Null. Irgendjemand denkt sich das aus und könnte man, also jetzt mal an die Juristen da draußen gefragt, könnte man ein Gesetz erlassen, das sich reimt? Also ist, wäre das, oder gibt es irgendeine Regel, dass das halt neutral, also das ist... Ich glaube schon, dass es darf. Also mit Schönen Jambus zum Trocheus, also darf man in Reihenformen. Es wird auch mit Sicherheit Gesetzestexte geben, die sich reimen. Glaube ich nicht. Weil die juristisch am einwandfreiesten formuliert sind. Telefoniert. Hat sich Telefon da reingeschlichen. Sorry. Weiß ich auch nicht. Also der würdeste Freundliche Versprecher aller Zeiten. Willst du gerade telefonieren, Stefan? Ja, ich muss echt gerade kurz telefonieren. Hast du ein verdrängtes Bedürfnis? Ja, ich will nicht kurz telefonieren. Du bist der langweiligste Mensch der Welt. Das ist dein tiefes Geheimnis. Er musste die ganze Zeit über telefonieren. Ich glaube, das geht, oder? Also ich meine, irgendjemand muss dir einen Vorschlag machen. Ich glaube, es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass der, ich glaube, da gibt es wenig Rumgebullschitte bei Gesetzestexten. Eben, aber wenn jetzt jemand einfach, du hast einen Gesetzestext, der einwandfrei ist, juristisch irgendwie, da ist alles drin, aber der reimt sich halt. Gibt es dann irgendeinen, also dann irgendwie beim Bundesgesetz, Bundesrat, Parlament, ir solcher eine von diesem Verein, die dann sagt, eine
Sache, gutes Gesetz, wunderbar,
ähm, weniger Stromverbrauch,
ganz toll, irgendwie die
zehn Deutschen, die am meisten Strom verbrauchen,
werden rausgeschmissen, gut.
Das reimt sich ja, ne?
Ja.
Was soll ich anstimmen?
Also, nee, ich hab
nichts dagegen, aber ist... Ich meine, das kann man nicht ernst nehmen, weil es sich reimt oder was. Naja, wir wollen alle Strom sparen, damit die Kinder noch was davon haben, die grössten... Haben. Davon haben. Es ist ein unreiner Reim auch noch nebenbei. Ja, wir fanden das nett. Ob wir trockene Gesetzestexte lesen müssen, es macht auf Dauer keinen Spaß mehr. Ja, aber da ist so ein Scratch and Sniff auch noch dabei, und das riecht irgendwie so nach Minze. Das macht auf Dauer keinen Spaß mehr, dann machen Sie auch unseren Job und kommen mal her. Wer sind Sie eigentlich? Kann er raus? Nein. Sind Sie einer von diesen Witzabgeordneten? Nee, ich bin hier ein bisschen, die Stimmung ein bisschen aufzuhellen. Das ist halt kein schöner Job. Wir müssen die ganze Zeit neue Gesetzestexte schreiben. Jetzt mal an die Juristen da draußen, falls es jemanden gibt, der irgendwie gerade an einem Gesetzestext werkelt, versucht da mal einen Reim einzubauen. Kann man mal offen sagen, wir hatten ja mal einen grossen Shitstorm bei Gute Arbeit Originals. Ja. Und wir mussten dazu eine Pressemitteilung veröffentlichen. Nee, wir mussten sie nicht veröffentlichen, wir haben sie vorbereitet. Ach genau, wir mussten sie nicht veröffentlichen, wir haben sie vorbereitet. Und unsere Idee war, die zu reimen. Ja. Unsere Idee war, einfach zu sagen, wie lustig wäre es mit diesem ernsten Text. Wir sind ja im Endeffekt immer noch ein Comedy-Channel. Wenn wir jetzt als Comedy-Channel die Aufgabe haben, einen ernsten Entschuldigungs-Pressetext zu schreiben, dann haben wir doch auch da eine gewisse Unterhaltungspflicht. Ja, absolut. Auch vertraglich, ja. Warum nicht einfach dann diesen Pressetext zumindest reimen und gucken, ob es jemand merkt und dann auch zu sehen, ob DVD-L den einfach so abtippen. Oder ob die die Reime rausnehmen würden. Das ist ja die Frage, ob es dann irgendwie, wenn dann das Gesetzestext gedruckt wird, nehmen die die Reime raus. Aber es war so, dass die Ansage kam, hey, wir wissen nicht, wie groß das Thema noch wird, bereitet schon mal ein Statement vor. Und das, vor allem, ich finde es nicht mehr. Ich habe das schon so oft gesucht, weil ich habe noch ganz viele Ordner mit guter Arbeitsscheiss und irgendwie alte Texte, die nicht benutzt wurden. Ich finde diesen Text nicht mit diesem gereimten Statement. Ich weiß noch, dass ich ihn geschrieben habe. Vor allem das Lustige daran fand ich, dass der ganz normal angefangen hat, aber dann das Reimometer immer weiter hochgedreht wurde im Verlauf des Textes. Also du merkst es halt, am Anfang war es gut noch, irgendwann ging es die Reime aus, am Anfang hat man es noch nicht gemerkt, am Anfang war es eher subtil, irgendwann hat man sich aber auch, man neigt nicht mehr dazu, die Satzstruktur zu ändern, um und Subjekt-Predikat-Objekt reinfolgen und baut zu werfen, um den Reim zu erzeugen. Und das war dann irgendwann schwierig, enjeu beumance einzubauen. Was? Enjeu beumance. Viele beumance, oder was? Enjeu beumance ist das Stilmittel, die grammatikalische Satzstruktur zu ändern und dem Reim zu beugen, unterzuordnen. Das ist weil, du willst sagen, die Struktur des Satzes verändern du musst, damit man sich dieses Stilmittel ist bewusst. Damit du von Clara kriegst den Kuss, ja. Okay. Das ist ein Engembouement. Nicht schlecht. Stilmittel der Woche? Stilmittel der Woche. Na komm, was soll der Geiz? Ist Stilmittel der Woche. Ist Stil-Woche, ja. Finde ich ganz gut, hat's verdient. Wie war das in der Woche, hast du so viel erlebt, warst du schön, du warst ja in Bayreuth. Ja, das war fantastisch, viel Musik gehört, wirklich ganz toll, viel gestritten auch mit Leuten. Ihr habt ja vielleicht in der Presse gelesen, diese eine weirde Sache, ich habe mich geprügelt mit dem Prominenten. Du warst da mit drin oder was?
Ich war mit in den Prügeler, ja. Krass. Ja, was da für Sätze fielen. Ich bin auch großer Fan von Wagner, aber nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad. Und viele Sätze, die konnte ich nicht mehr unterstreichen. Und dann habe ich Pierre M. Krause, da sind viele Prominente da, einfach ins Gesicht geschlagen. Ja, ja, ja. Aber bist du dann eher ein Rangler oder eher ein wirklich Boxer? Also schlägst du wirklich die Hiebe aus oder ist es eher so ein Schucken und Schubsen und Rangeln? Nee, einfach, ich bin da sehr emotional in solchen Situationen, deswegen will ich einfach primär erst mal wehtun und dann wegrennen auch schnell. Also ein gezielter Hieb ins Gesicht und dann weg? Wegrennen auch, ja. Wegrennen, wirklich. Ja, und er hat angefangen gerufen und sowas. Peinliche Sachen. Ja, ja, ja. Die sind mir auch egal, sind Hauptsache ich werde nicht auch noch geschlagen. Zu weinen, weinen, wegrennen. Ich will nicht geschlagen werden. Ja, es war auf jeden Fall eine grosse, habt ihr ja gelesen, war eine ganz, ganz grosse, weirde Sache. Ich war noch nie in der Schlägerei. Und deine Woche über deine Woche. Ja, ja, grossartig. Wie war Campen? Grossartig, super. Warst du auch in der Presse? Ja, ich war auch in der Presse, ja. Es kam da zu diesem kleinen Eklat. Wie gesagt, wir wussten nicht, dass die Fische im See eine sehr spezielle Rasse sind und tatsächlich, dass die einzigen Exemplare der Spezies sind, die noch existieren. Ja, wir hätten nicht alle 200 essen müssen, aber die waren so lecker. Alter. Und du denkst dir dann irgendwann, die laufen halt auch nicht weg. Butterfische, warum nennt man die Butterfische, wenn die nicht zum Essen da sind? Nennt die nicht so. Wenn ihr nicht wollt, dass wir die essen, nennt sie nicht Butterfische. I can't believe it's Butterfish. Butter bei die Fische. Und man konnte die einfach greifen, aus dem Wasser greifen und einfach direkt reinbeissen. manche Tiere kann man ja direkt essen. Austern. Austern kannst du direkt essen. Naja, die tun viel dafür, dass sie nicht gegessen werden. Schade. Gut, gut. Aber die kannst du knacken und essen. Wie begeistert bist du von dem neuen Austern-Emoji? Noch nicht gesehen. 2019 unter den neuen Emojis auch die Auster. Ehrlich gesagt nicht gebraucht. Mit einer schönen Perle drin. Gibt es einen Pokerchip? Nein. Noch keinen Pokerchip? Pokerchip und es gibt auch nicht den, der zur Tür rausgeht. Den braucht auch niemand, weil du hast die Tür und den rausgeh-Emoji. Na gut, aber Pokerchip, da hast du mittlerweile, aber hat man Würfel eigentlich? Ja. Ja gut, kannst du auch mal. Mehrere, glaube ich, mehrere Würfel. Und du hast jetzt auch den Gähnenden-Emoji. Es gab keinen Gähnenden- Emoji? Nee, aus Angst vor passiv-aggressiver Verwendung. Es gab nicht den gähnenden Emoji und bei unseren Vorschlägen war auch nicht der gähnende Emoji dabei? Das merkt man dann immer erst. Pirat. Ja, aber wie machst du einen Pirat? Ein großer Hut. Großer Hut, Holzbein, Augenklappe. Bein, ein Emoji. Das ist ein ganzer Mensch. Ganzer Mensch. Das ist einer von den ganzen Menschen. Da gibt es viele ganze Menschen. Ja, aber willst du ja nicht eher so nur das Gesicht? Dann hast du so einen Hut und dann mit so diesem, wie heißt der, Jumping Jack, Skull Jack? Keine Ahnung. Papagei auf dem Board. Nee, dieser, dieser, dieser. So gimmicky, ne, ehrlich gesagt, Piraten sind so gimmicky. Also, eigentlich bräuchte ich so nur ein paar Papageien auf der Schulter. Nein, wir haben uns auch für dreieckiger, großer schwarzer Hut, Flagge mit Totenkopf, Holzbein, Haken, Hand und Augenklappe entschieden. Sorry, der wollte so viele USPs, das ist ultra nervig, viel zu viel, zu spezieller Mensch. Es ist zu speziell, ich kann ja nicht mal eins abgeben, dass wir einfach so sagen, wir müssen da nochmal neu ordnen, kann nicht die metallische Hakenhand, kann die nicht irgendwie Gärtner bekommen, dass man sagen, oh Karneval, ich verkleide mich als Gärtner, ach krass, dann hast du auch so eine Hakenhand, oder? Ja klar, natürlich, hallo, sehr logisch, so und dass man einfach sagt, der Pirat gibt halt dann zumindest eins ab. Pirat hat zu viel Gimmicks. Aber Hakenhand, damit man die Seile entlangrutschen kann, oder? Nee, weil du deine Hand verloren hast im Gefecht. Ja, aber wenn du dann sagst, gut, du kannst jetzt entweder einen riesigen Löffel haben anstatt einer Hand oder einen Haken. Dann kannst du ja austauschen. Ja. Du kannst ein Messer dran kleben, dann kannst du schneiden. Ja, aber dann verlierst du die. Dann sagst du, Schatz, Schatz. Miep, miep,bedienung. Warum ist das Gewinde so lang? Warum nicht was Magnetisches? Damit stabil ist. Ein Magnet ist zu unsicher, Schatz. Warum knietscht es, fliechtscht es mit dem Gewinde? Öl mal lieber. Ölhand. Hier ist deine Ölhand. M öls. Ich kann es nicht ölen, weil es die gleiche Hand ist. Hier wurden übrigens noch 20 Minuten rausgeschnitten an der Stelle. Ja, und dann diese Schiffe auch gimmicky, auch wie die aussahen, diese Halbmonde, so hinten diese Schiffskajüte hinten. Ah, das ist schon gut. Willst du Bock mehr? Ich würde mir immer denken, die haben sich doch konstant verfahren, oder? Ja. Also ich meine jetzt wirklich keinen Columbus-Hate, null, null, nullinger, wirklich. Du kannst ruhig, du kannst ihn nicht. Nee, nee, nee, ich will nichts sagen. Warum nicht? Du kannst ihn nicht halten. Aber sorry, wie kann man denn bitte Indien verfehlen? Um so viele Meter. Also wirklich, ich meine, hast du meine Karte angeschaut? Amerika ist links, Indien ist rechts. Also ein kolossales Missverständnis. Die sind einfach in die falsche Richtung gefahren. Und dann findest du, denkst du, er ist Indien gefunden. Wann kam eigentlich der Punkt, wie lange hat das eigentlich gedauert, bis die gecheckt haben, dass sie falsch sind? Naja, ich glaube, es hat länger gedauert. Ich glaube, bis heute heissen Indianer Indianer. Schon klar, aber ich meine, erst als sie zurückgefahren sind, dachten sie ja, wir haben da so ein Land gefunden, aber die haben nicht indisch gesprochen. Ja, aber es scheint ein regionaler Dialekt zu sein. Ja, passt schon. Ja, passt schon. Haben wir es doch. Haben wir vielleicht das falsche Land? Kann man ein falsches Land entdecken? Ist aber noch gut, ein Land zu entdecken. Ja, vor allem, du willst ja nicht unsinsibel sein und sagen so, ihr seid aber keine echten Inder, oder? Und er so, was heißt das denn? Das ist ein Heisen. Ha? Die waren auch damals schon so PC, die wollten nichts falsch machen. Ja Ja, und auch so ein Känguru und so, ja, kann ja jeder machen, kann ja jeder Beutel haben, wie er will. Ist ja völlig in Ordnung. Ja? Also, nee, ja klar, klar, nur über, nee, überhaupt kein Stress. Tier mit Beutel, na, auf, hallo, nur weil, nein! Und dann eine so, warum sind hier Kängurus, sind wir,? Hallo, klar, können hier Kängurus sein. In Indien? Ja! Woher weißt du das Wort für das Tier? Hast du es gerade so benannt? Steht bei ihm Namensschild. Hä? Namensschild, Känguru. Herr Känguru. Das ist doch kein Känguru. Steht bei ihm drauf, auf dem Namensschild. Stimmt denn die Geschichte, dass dieses Känguru, dass dieses, dass die angekommen sind und dann haben die auf ein Tier gezeigt und haben gefragt, wie heißt das? Und dann haben die gesagt Känguru und später stellt sich raus, dass Känguru einfach nur heißt, ich verstehe nicht, was du von mir willst, du Kasper. Ja. Aber vielleicht ist es auch falsch. Ich kenne es aus Arrival und aber aus... Nee, aber da wird es schon als falsche Geschichte... Richtig. Aber ist es richtig, dass es falsch ist? Weil der Drehbuchautor hat damit ja einen Twist reingebracht, der hat gesagt, ah, unsere Protagonistin hier ist so clever, dass sie sogar Geschichten verwenden kann, die falsch sind, um andere Leute zu überzeugen. Vielleicht sogar so clever, dass sie eine richtige Geschichte verwenden kann, weil sie so sicher ist, dass Leute das nicht kennen. Die Frage ist, wie clever ist der Drehbuchautor? Hat der extra den Twist noch selber sich ausgedacht, dass sie falsch ist? Warum, Danny will Löff anrufen? Den kenne ich ja mittlerweile ganz gut. Danny! Danny! Danny! Danny! Danny! Manche Leute muss man einfach nur beschwören, die erscheiden dann einfach. Danny, weh da! Hast du ein Auto gerade? Pfff... Helikopter. Pfff... Super nervig, dass er immer wenn ich mir einen Namen gehöre, eben hinkommen muss. Wie Batman so ein bisschen, ne? Als ich arm war, ein großes Problem. Jetzt, wo ich reich bin, Helikopter hab, easy.
Perfekt.
Ich war heute auf Bild.de,
muss ich nochmal zugeben,
und es hat mir den Tag ruiniert.
Wo ich dachte, wir haben neulich mal vor zwei Folgen über Triggerwarnungen gesprochen.
Bräuchte man eigentlich mal hier ab und zu
eine Triggerwarnung. Falls ihr
Triggerwarnung würdige
Stellen im Podcast entdeckt, dann schreibt sie gerne auf die Puffopedia. Wenn ihr nicht auf Kindstode steht, sag ich ganz offen, war das gerade eine kleine Triggerwarnung für was jetzt kommt. Gut. Denn ich war auf Bild.de und ich dachte mir, kurz mal in der Mittagspause einfach mal auf andere Gedanken kommen und dann haben die mir den Tag ruiniert, weil ich dachte, holy shit, einfach nur die Tagline, ähm, Opa lässt, sorry, Opa lässt Baby vom Kreuzfahrtschiff fallen. Holy shit. Und ich habe nichts anderes gekonnt, als mir den Frust und die Trauer in meinem Kopf und die schwarzen Gedanken wegzulachen, weil ich dachte, das kann nicht wahr sein.
Oh fuck.
Opa hat das Kind fallen lassen.
Nein.
Opa lässt das Baby fallen in den Ozean. Wie furchtbar ist das denn? Und man denkt, what the fuck? Und man denkt nur, die arme Tochter, die ihr Kind verloren hat und den Vater ja auch zu einem gewissen Punkt. Die kann doch den Opa nicht mehr in die Augen gucken. Opa. Kommt man, oh Heinrich. Opa, dass du immer einen Urlaub ruinieren musst. Aber das ist schon schwierig. Und dann sitzt du nächstes Weihnachten mit dem am Esstisch und dann sagst du... Du lässt dir so die Gabel fallen und du guckst ihn noch an. Und dann sagst du, ja, seid ein bisschen zu spät gekommen. Opa, du hast aber mein Kind ins Meer geworfen. Ja, mein Gott, das war vor ein Jahr. Ich hab's fallen lassen. Ich hab's nicht absichtlich geworfen. Warum ist es dann so weit geflogen, Opa? Och Gott, es ist schnell gefahren. Warum sagt das Kamera-Footage was anderes? Und er lässt so eine Gabel fallen und du guckst ihn so an, dich so. Immer lässt du alles fallen. Und dann kommen die Nachbarn zu Gast. Oh, kann ich mal euer Kind halten? So, ich ganz kurz,, wir können auch jetzt mit der Karaoke anfangen. Ich dachte mir, holy shit, das ruiniert doch die Familie. Das geht doch alles. Was ist das erste Thema, über das man redet, wenn man nicht mehr darüber redet? Kann man reinkommen und so? Fernsehprogramm. Das Wetter ist super, oder? Fernsehprogramm. Wie oft muss der Opa sorry sein? Ja, vor allem aber auch blöd, dann rennst du zum Kapitän, dann sagst du Kind über Bord und der Kapitän sagt. Ja. Also ich meine, also ich glaube, wenn... Was gibt es zum Mittag? Oder ich meine, wenn ein Erwachsener über Bord fallen würde, dann würde man umdrehen, oder? So ein Kreuzfahrt. Mann über Bord, ja. Ich glaube, es gibt schon ein Baby-Überbord-Manöver. Ist das ein anderes Manöver? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Kleinerer Wendekreis. Ich weiß es nicht. Ach Gott, sorry. Kann es denn schwimmen? Nee. Na dann, volle Kraft voraus! Da habe ich mit einem Kollegen geshared, diese Information, weil ich es furchtbar fand, in dem Moment zu fassen, zu konziden in meinem Kopf. Da hat er gesagt, ja, aber Kinder sind auch natürliche Schwimmer. Wo ich kurz lachen musste, weil ich dachte, ich habe mir kurz vorgestellt, dass man so ein Baby ins Pool wirft und es hat so die perfekte Kraultechnik. Ja, ja, genau. Und es krault direkt los mit seinen kleinen Becken. Stößt sich auch so vom Beckenrand ab. Genau, und macht auch diese Rolle unter Wasser und so und so, der perfekte Schwimmer. Aber ich meine, wie tröstest du eine Person so? Ist ja auch arschkalt. Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite... Heute Abend können sie schön noch weiter feiern. Und ich meine, ey, du mochtest doch immer Mowgli so gerne als Geschichte. Vielleicht wächst es jetzt bei Delfinen auf oder so. Das habe ich auch gedacht. Nach zehn Jahren kommst du wieder an die leckige Stelle und dann kommt so ein Wassermensch, ein wunderschöner Aquaman-artiger Rrrr. Steht so vor der Tür und, warum seid ihr nicht umgedreht, ihr Vollidioten? Ja genau, und spricht so die Sprache des Meeres und hinter ihm hat so ein Rrrr, Rrrr und hat so Schwimmhäute und so einen wunderschönen weiblichen Meerjungfrauenkörper. Ja, und Opa sitzt in der Ecke und man nickt ihm nur so zu. Ja, und dann macht er so grossen, schwingt so hoch, dreht so ein paar Looping, ist es wieder ein Weiten des Meeres. Ja, wir versuchen halt gerade auf unsere Art mit diesem furchtbaren Thema klarzukommen. Ja, aber das muss doch regelmäßig, also Kreuzfahrten muss doch regelmäßig passieren, oder, dass Leute über Bord fahren. Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen regelmäßig, ich habe Sterben auch viel über Bord, ich habe auch selbst Mörder, Sostmorde auf Kreuzfahrtschiffen, damals bei der ganzen Danny-Ruburg-Sache kam, wurde auch immer mitgesagt, dass es häufiger vorkommt. Vor allem, also ich, ich, ich, ich verheirte mich auch die falsche Vorstellung von Kreuzfahrtschiffen, aber da wird schon auch gesoffen, oder, und gefeiert. Wird gesoffen und gefickt und gefeiert.
Weil Kreuzfahrten sind ja recht teuer.
Ist das schon so High Society
oder ist das dann so Malle?
Es gibt solche und solche. Ich glaube, die gemeine
Aida-Club-Kreuzfahrt ist, glaube ich, Malle.
Es gibt aber auch halt die
Queen of the Seas,
Master of the Seas.
Vor allem, ich glaube, alleine diese eine Szene aus Titanic,
mit dem Ich bin der König der Welt, ist für
so viele Überbordgänge
verantwortlich. Weil, erst wenn du bist betrunk Vielen Dank. Master of the Scenes. Und dann denkst du dir, so, DiCaprio, wo bist du jetzt? Ja, wo bist du jetzt? Nicht, und dann ruft der andere Freund, nein, das Schiff geht unter, nicht die Menschen. Und auf der Tür hätten beide Platz gehabt. Was hat das denn jetzt mit dem Thema zu tun? Halt die Fresse! Ist ein Filmfehler, ich wollte es nur mal anmerken. Gut, man über Bord, dann ist es viel zu spät, kommt das Manöver. Ich wollte es nur sagen, man über Bord. Wie trötet dann ein Schiff bei man über Bord, weiß ich nicht genau. Aber wollten die jetzt nicht noch eine Titanic noch mal neu fahren lassen? Ne, neu verfilmen. Ne, neue Titanic bauen. Und auch wieder gegen Eisberg fahren lassen. Und auch noch mal filmen. Komm, lass uns, das war doch geil, lass uns einfach alles nochmal machen. Ja. Es gibt ja keine Eisberge mittlerweile mehr, von daher passt das schon. Ach, wir werden so... Stimmt, eigentlich kann man Titanic keinen Remake machen. Ne, heutzutage wird es auch nicht mehr funktionieren. Fährt gegen Atomobut, Obut der Nordkoreaner. Wir kommen glücklich in New York und alle so, ja, weil es keine Eisberge mehr gibt.
Deswegen gibt es keinen Spannungsbogen mehr.
Ja, aber das ist eine positive Botschaft. Und deswegen kann das Schiff nicht untergehen.
Danke Klimawandel! Und alle, danke Klimawandel! Moment mal, was? Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da Musiker, ja, irgendwie ganz komisch. We're a film, komische Botschaft. Komische, aber gute. Aber ist die Botschaft vom Titanic nicht, diese scheisse Eisberge müssen mal weg? Eigentlich schon. Vielleicht hat die Klimawandel gesagt, ja sorry, der war zu dumm. Die Natur hat gesagt, komm, paar gerade hoch. Komm, fahr, wir fahren jetzt weg. Fahr weg, weg mit den scheisse Eisbergen, ey. Wo fahren die hin? Eisberg, Eisbär, Eiszapfen, Polarfuchs. Es gibt nochmal alle Tiere auch nochmal in Weiss. Im Eisdunstkreis. Das ist wie so weisse Schokolade. Es gibt alles so KitKat und gibt es nochmal in Weiss halt in der Antarktis. Muss ja nicht, muss nicht sein, finde ich. Ne, die können weg, dass du diese neuen Sachen brauchst. Neuartige, brauchst nicht, brauchst nicht.
Jetzt kommen ja viele einmal mit Eisbären.
Ich finde die gruselig, die haben diese, es gibt schöne Bären und sehr süße Bären und so, ich kenne immer der gruselige Bär, der grosse Bär, nein, Braunbär ist der viel grössere Bär, zumindest nach dem Naturhistorischen Museum in den USA nachzuurteilen, und die haben diese süßen, dicken Teddygesichter, aber nicht der Eisbär. Der Eisbär hat dieses fiese, kleine Terrier-Gesicht. So fies.
Bist du sicher, dass das ein Eisbär war? Ich bin mir schon sicher.
Macht ein Eisbär eigentlich auch einen Winterschlaf und dann einfach ...
Macht der ein Geräusch? Macht der, bellt der? Ja.
Brrrr, brrrr, brrrr.
Oder der Eismann hat einfach so ein schönes ... Was haben die? War das mal was für dich? Gibt es Schnee? Schneit es eigentlich in der Antarktis? Oder in der Arktis? Oder ist es dann eher so Eis? Graupel. Viel Graupel? Graupel. Graupel und Hagel. Primär
Graupelschauer.
Das ist eine verrückte Welt da oben.
Geil, dass es so etwas gibt, also bald nicht mehr, aber cool, dass es
so ein Eislevel auf
der Erde einfach so. Es gibt halt
Lava-Level. Gibt es halt Feuerladen?
Das überlege ich mir auch, ob man da nicht
eher so Lava-Level. Ich meine, die
Menschheitsgeschichte ist wie ein Zelda-Spiel. Wir waren
jetzt halt lange in dem Eislevel und jetzt kommt halt der Lava-Level oder Wüsten-Level.
Hast du eine Switch und hast mal Into the Breathe of the Wild?
Ich habe Breathing the Wild habe ich gespielt, so lange bis Gunnar Krupp meinen Spielstand gelöscht hat.
Dann habe ich aufgehört und dann hatte ich keinen Bock mehr anzufangen.
Echt jetzt? Ich habe mit sehr vielen Leuten darüber gesprochen und alle haben an dem Elefanten aufgehört.
Ja?
Alle, ich auch, an dem Elefanten. Ich habe den Endboss nicht besiegen können, weil ich viel zu früh bei dem Elefanten war. Sidequest interessiert mich nicht, ich will die Welt sehen, deswegen reise ich rum, deswegen reise ich mit zum nächsten Ziel. Und dann habe ich oben zu wenig Sternen, Herzchen gehabt, zu wenig Leben und der Endboss beim Elefanten hat mich sofort besiegt. Wie vielen da draußen geht es auch so, dass sie beim Elefanten gesagt haben, nee, komm. Weil mir geht es beim Spiel ja auch nicht darum, ich will ja nicht gut sein im Spiel. Wenn ich dreimal gegen diesen Endboss verliere, dann bin ich genervt. Ich will nicht besser sein als das Spiel. Ich will das Spiel spielen, ich will die Narrative, ich will die Geschichte erleben. Ich will nicht gut darin sein, in diesem Minigame-artigen Ausweichen und dann zuschlagen.
Verstehst du?
Ich will das exakte Gegenteil, aber ja, sofort.
Ich will einfach weiterkommen.
Ich will die Gegend erkunden und dann weitermachen im Spiel.
Dieses Minigame hat für mich keinen Spaß.
Ausweichen, jetzt den richtigen Knopf, an den richtigen Stelle drücken und dann dazustechen.
Das mache ich dreimal, dann bin ich ein bisschen besser, aber da habe ich kein Interesse mehr daran.
Du bist das Gegenteil? Ich bin das Gegenteil, die Geschichte interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Ich will hier irgendwie schön Bogen schießen und dann genau treffen und dann überlege ich genau, wie muss ich dem in den Lauf schießen, dass ich genau treffe. Aber ich habe, wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt ein 2DS. Das ist ein 3DS ohne 3D.
Man kann da aber die 3DS-Spiele drauf spielen, weil ich habe einen Billigen gebraucht, einfach für den Urlaub.
Gibt es da einen 1DS?
Das ist schwierig.
Ganz merkwürdig ist halt der 4DS, der ist halt super. Er kann unserer Dimension nicht wahrgenommen werden.
Der 5DS kommt leider nur in einer anderen Dimension raus, bei der Nintendo-PressMitteilung. Leider nicht hier verfügbar, aber er's Theme. Aber gibt es spezielle spielen. Auf der Ocarina konnte ich ein paar Lieder spielen, nicht die Lächeln nicht Zelda's Theme.
Aber gibt es spezielle Lieder für die Ocarina?
Ja, nö, ja, Zelda's Theme. Ocarina of Time ist, glaube ich, das einzige Lied, das speziell für die Ocarina geschrieben wurde.
Es ist ein sehr wenig beachtetes Instrument, völlig zu Recht auch nicht beachtet, weil es ist auch nicht verdient.
Ich muss dann ehrlich sagen, wenn mir jemand gegenübersteht und sagt, ja, ich bin der weltbeste Ocarina-Spieler, würde ich sagen. So be it. Klingt ein bisschen nach Zeitverschwendung. So be it. Aber ja. Geh deines Weges, aber mach vielleicht was Vernünftiges. Lern vielleicht nebenbei, mach noch einen Master in irgendwas oder so. Mach noch einen Master in Agrarwissenschaft, das ist wichtig für die Zukunft. Oder Klarinette, zumindest Klarinette.
Du kannst einen Baum, geh mal raus, häng eine Schaukel auf.
Okay.
Und dann zog er davon, Ocarina spielend.
Aber kann das mal jemand als Remix machen von diesem Ich will nicht auffallen Lied? Es ist immer Bambadam, Badam, Badam. Was ist das meist gepfiffene Ich will nicht auffallen Lied? Gute Frage. Und ist es in allen Kulturen gleich? Geh mal nach Japan und sag mal, was pfeift jemand, der gerade nicht auffallt.
Man will ja möglichst kein, du willst ja nicht auffallen, du willst ja möglichst kein Lied zu, was existiert.
Also keine bekannte Melodie.
Also schwank man im Metrum schon mal, macht sowas wie
Ich bin nicht da, ich bin hier.
Bitte?
Sie sind da. Ja, ich bin nicht da. Ich sehe sie. Ja, es ist schon auch ein Lüppdüdü. Ey, mach da mal einen Remix. Wir machen, weil die nächsten zwölf Intros sind exklusiv nur Remixe von dem Ich bin nicht da Lied. Ja. Und frag mal, falls ihr in Japan seid, wir kriegen ja immer wieder Nachrichten. Ich will so gerne nach Japan. Ja, wir kriegen immer Nachrichten von Leuten, ich bin in Japan, in Japan gibt es ein Salzmuseum, hat mir jemand geschrieben, super. Und falls ihr in Japan seid, fragt mal jemanden, wie da das Lied geht, wenn man nicht auffallen möchte und nehmt das auf und schickt es uns, wir wollen kulturübergreifende Kulturforschung betreiben und das würde mich interessieren. Oder hier in China oder irgendeine fremde Kultur. Das Podcast ist wo wir betreiben kulturübergreifende Kulturforschung. Das ist hier ein catchy Titel, das machen wir so. Das neue Fit kann auch lustig ist, wir betreiben kulturübergreifende Kulturforschung. Greift zu im Shop, es gibt neue T-Shirts, kulturübergreifende Kulturforschung.de .org.de war schon vergeben. Und wir freuen uns sehr, wenn ihr mitmachen wollt.
Ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine schöne Woche, haut rein. Ehrlich jetzt? Dass ihr euch bald auch... Ich hätte es schwören können, dass die Folge noch nicht vorbei ist. Ich freue mich sehr. Ich hoffe, dass ihr bald auch schönen Urlaub habt und ihn genießt, in welcher Form auch immer. Ansonsten viel Freude da nach draußen und wir heben ab und sagen Lebewohl.